You've done all this research and
competitor analysis, so now what?
Well, use it.
You can get sharp on your original idea
or alter the idea based on what you
learned from user research and
other early idea validation.
We have four activities that can help
you get more clarity on your idea.
The first is a Twitter description,
how would you announce your product
in a 140 characters, or less?
This activity helps you get laser
focus on the key user value and
your product market fit.
The second is you could write
a future press release.
How would your product
first appear in the news?
You can use this structure to
focus yourself and your team.
The structure ensures that you
capture your future vision.
The third is a one
page executive summary.
This is the shortest and
clearest way to define your product.
And finally, the fourth is
an experienced strategy template.
This template is appropriate for
defining new product categories.
And in the instructor notes, you'll find
templates for each of these activities.
Take a minute to read over them, and
think about which one would help
you get more clarity on your idea.